(bright music)
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] The Zapotecs are the main
indigenous group living in Oaxaca, Mexico.
Once a thriving civilization
of the pre-Colonial era,
they still keep their
traditions very much alive.
Introducing Zapotecan Abigail Mendoza,
one of Mexico's most respectable chefs.
(speaking in foreign language)
Cooking since the age of 5, she has become
world famous for keeping the ancestral
and traditional Zapotecan
ways of cooking alive.
(speaking in foreign language)
With these tools, Abigail is making dishes
like the seguesa, a pre-Hispanic mole,
which has a corn-based
sauce, chilies and turkey.
She also cooks chilies directly on coal,
stuffed with squash blossom seeds,
and topped with a melted Oaxacan cheese.
And these are all foods
that were eaten thousands of years ago.
(speaking in foreign language)